hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Daniel
Seibert we're gonna review the trailer
today the official call the duty
advanced warfare exo-zombies havoc
trailer I'm looking at why it's rated M
right now for blood and gore drug
references intense violence and strong
language and zombies and zombies this
sounds like one hell of an experience
suck it would an Atlas drop the bomb
they hoped it would finish the war
instead I challenged a free show like no
one has ever seen a lot [ __ ] all three
zombies
heavy security
Baxter to love it
shame
[ __ ] hate the Atlas corporation
holy mother [ __ ] that looks [ __ ]
awesome I love it
when you hear to call of duty and
zombies you get exactly that oh and
they're not slow-moving zombies they're
like left for dead
style where they're like [ __ ] jetting
at you the whole time and I kind of like
that Resident Evil vibe where it's like
a bunch of different zombies and it's
you know like even the dogs with the
[ __ ] three mouth thing they got going
on that was pretty sweet I'm especially
excited that we got a whole [ __ ] cast
of [ __ ] John Malkovich John Malkovich
Jill Rose McGowan built accent and
[ __ ] Jon Bernthal holy [ __ ] I mean it
was quitting Norman Reedus isn't isn't
Silent Hill yeah but to hear that Jon
Bernthal from The Walking Dead is
actually in a zombie game is so [ __ ]
cool out of anyone from The Walking Dead
he was like the perfect character to
take I mean though it's not the same
character but yeah great cast member to
take oh dude that looks like a total
blast dude my friends and I would play
three or four-hour sessions of black ops
nazi zombies ladies we would sit down
and we would drink beer for three to
four hours doing like one big huge run
of nazi zombies there's one thing that
Call of Duty does very well it's the
goddamn zombies zombies they get it down
cuz the Call of Duty gameplay is a blast
enough as it is
and now you're throwing the zombies in
the mix it makes it that much more
exciting and the fact that they have
like this cast assembled you think about
like an actual film and you're like how
would be the perfect cast for this movie
and I like how the characters look like
the actors - oh this is such a great
freaking job modeling them and it's neat
how advanced warfare has Kevin Spacey in
it now the zombie one has all these
other actors - now you wanna know
something I was not gonna buy call of
duty advanced warfare because I'm you
know I have destiny I'm gonna buy it now
oh yeah I'm buying advanced warfare for
this specific purpose it looks like it
takes place in a
one setting it doesn't go all over the
place like a shy hardwood zombies
traditionally like it's probably going
to be one big map okay then they'll be
like a couple other deal because I
imagine this is DLC I'm pretty sure this
is there'll be another DLC that adds
another map hopefully they get the
actors back into quickly say a few more
lines yeah send them on their way
and because advanced warfare takes place
like in the near distant future
it actually makes more sense to have the
zombie theme going on this time around -
yeah because it's easier to believe a
zombie story when it's like a little bit
further in the future I don't want them
with exoskeletons though they're gonna
be so freaking hard yeah that was nuts
and like they they come at you in packs
and stuff and we've seen like the
trailer for dying light we've seen the
trailer for Dead Island and those are
specific kind of zombie games like what
I love about this is it is the Call of
Duty gameplay versus zombies it doesn't
look like they changed everything up and
like they made it just right and the
horror theme they got going it looks
like a scary game - oh yeah like you got
the fast gameplay style because Resident
Evil's like more tension-filled and this
has the fast gameplay style but with
zombies and it's like just looking
perfect them up zombie game you know
it's gonna be a lot of zombies coming at
you very fast yeah oh dude that's gonna
be a [ __ ] blast on Xbox Live - will
they allow you to play as a zombie you
think no no no why not it's it's cool
that's stupid what [ __ ] this game
hey serious no no no you stupid why
would you play as a zombie you do
nothing but by people as far as like
this because you know that this style of
Call of Duty is very you know it's a war
style going on this style does capture
the zombie the the raw gritty zombie
theme very well I was just expecting
Call of Duty but with zombies I wasn't
expecting like this feels like a genre
like that was something that really
surprised me just now I didn't play the
other one it looks like so much effort
efforts been putting in I mean if you
look at the models of the characters and
everything yeah it looks like there was
actually like a ton of effort put into
zombies because they get it yeah yeah
and I think the designs of the actors
looks better than what they did with
Kevin Spacey cuz like oh yeah just like
Kevin it looked like Kevin Spacey but
you're like it's kind of distracting
that it looks
Kevin Spacey this time around you're
like it's the right amount of animation
versus real life the texturing is really
well done absolutely skinning skinnies
getting skinny skinny there's more than
one way to skin a character if you guys
are new to the channel you can subscribe
to the real rejects and Dan has a gaming
channel where he does [ __ ] like that if
you're proud of me here so check that
out
Daniel Chao tree I see you giving me a
shout-out bra love from the UK I live
coconut sweep your chimney I will I will
would you walk us forward time he's
psychic he's psychic I see you giving me
a shout-out yeah that was in the past he
read the future and he saw it's giving
him a shout-out
that is awesome British people all have
that power oh I didn't know it's all
British people know what I learned today
is all Germans are bisexual and all
British people are mind reader's
how did you come upon that conclusion
it's pretty simple why did I say that
really weird it's basic observation
skills okay and Daniel Chaudhary he's a
mind reader I mean look at this guy
well there's one of them Indian British
guys looking at his photos I'm like this
guy's staring into my soul right now
yeah we're not creeping on Facebook No
so our Daniel Lauer oh I'm epic Dan hi
there
can you tell me if you have any
copyright thing for posting trailers on
YouTube I'm the only youtuber who does
not get any issues with copyright claims
they all let me monetize because they
love me and respect me and in return I
send them dick pics so you know
Universal Studios Warner Brothers they
love this guy yeah see I I didn't have
to make the joke he is the joke oh yeah
great Saul back I'm thinking about
creating a trailer analysis channel on
the same vibe as yours but in Portuguese
who's gonna watch it that it's in
Portuguese I don't want to be sure
there's no problem for uploading
trailers things okay serious answer yes
some studios will get upset at you for
doing that you know they'll be like yo
whoa
I know you're helping promote our movie
but cut the [ __ ] the other than that no
I mean most of the time it's pretty cool
it's pretty cool you know you just use
someone else's footage and then you do a
video about their footage and then yeah
you reap the profits Wow I feel dirty
you should feel dirty your Portuguese
trailer analysis channel that sounds
like something I will probably never
watch because I don't speak Portuguese
but we're excited about your endeavours
and this is one of your videos I'm
excited about your endeavors do you
really would nearly need another trailer
analysis channel in Portuguese real
rechecks Portuguese well most Portuguese
people speak English ah no I don't know
no I don't know you don't know much
about Portuguese neither do I anyway
Daniel ooh Rome no seriously good luck
on your channel I will help support you
in any way I can if we do a Portuguese
movie trailer review which I'll probably
never do I'll bring you on the channel
but most likely not because I probably
won't do that way to bring up hopes to
crush them bring him up again crush it
that's really my style I've noticed are
you gonna do that thing again no joke oh
there's an observation like how all
Germans are bisexual and all British
people can read mine now who's the
callback master
I'm the callback master yeah he jokes
like that Daniel